hello and welcome to see your plane I am
broker and yo okay in a bit of a trouble
to read the score against the sky hey
I'm sorry for the puzzled look I guess
what is the name name game I am broker
f11 game against them and three drawers
that was the weird part you don't have
that many drawers usually and yes
somehow so I played tons of draws
against the dollar but three out of four
is a lot so I'm playing them g6 Lyonya
against the way interesting variation
that leads to complex plane let's see
what he plays g-force looks likely
in those positions white has one
standard option to play d 5 after knight
to e7 takes Queen take so we get that
and what we get that the position
resembles some yeah king's indian style
plane in in this position or a very
similar position magnus carlsen actually
played Bishop h6 against kayaking in
invite i wonder if this is the precise
position might be actually it's not the
only option I can also play h 6 + f5
which I have done as well in games that
that's what hasn't played with black as
well yes played this kind of positional
against nakamura i think in one game
that took too long for this actually
okay so is he going for f form maybe he
is but maybe he just wants to play a
three that's it's also possible to know
wow that's sharp if I'm taking a form
okay if it takes f5 I thought I have g5
actually two to just keep the keep
things or is that wrong somehow I mean I
will ever get I would get at five you
know this is why I thought f4 wouldn't
be that grade and interesting
so if i take on our five with the night
you might have some look check Queen
take this 9494 is annoying
yeah but isn't that a set of all I can
go here rookie six ever create Queen d3
room checks is six should work I don't
see how keeping the ruckus what I'm
trying to say if it could establish a
piece only six that would be really bad
but I mean if he's not getting something
quickly I'm probably just winning this I
have 94 93 ideas or just g-form yeah he
g4 looks like the move to play consumer
I've got some week but still this is the
right okay I should really wastes time
on that so let's see i can take now and
then play f3 f4 is hanging I want to
ever have some tactic here maybe with
you can also take age for okay and I do
this first and then player 3 here right
or not I don't have any good discovery
here night h5 that's that's actually an
interesting way of playing just keep
this porn and asked him where he goes I
will create next yeah okay this is this
is something that's something I can play
you create next that looks a lot like a
king's gambit in some way you probably
will go to the 3m
no they were lacking why am i
overlooking stuffy or something Queenie
for okeee this is pretty nonsense that
that's really bad right so he has to go
down whoa ok ha so we had an idea and
dammit light f6 back though is that
doing much if I go back no one isn't
right this is ok friendly to move the
rock now a check so he has to check I
didn't see that check at all cap but
fortunately for me it was not disastrous
yeah so I think the policy is too good
not to take and I'll threatening g3 this
is the main thing right if I drag queens
i'm just a pawn up but geez really looks
from looks like a stronger threat don't
know here Queen a force of the head
shouldn't shouldn't be enough parfum to
prevent u 3m maybe that's not possible
no he's not mated huh it's not getting
chick mated okay it still looks right so
check check 491 maybe that wasn't
actually the best clock but ok let's
let's do it let's do this time morning
yeah it wasn't it wasn't the cleanest
way to to play this position pretty sure
anyway let's get get this on their file
where it belongs Queen g3 f94 I think it
might be it might be actually very quite
strong for me maybe the FI looks like a
huge issue here King it to assess idea
can I move the night somehow to know
this is pinned anyway okay so let's go
here yes this is the thing okay the time
is a consideration here some place in
butch's check
okay p porn is also a checked.check 20
seconds this is a good idea of him get
this to form okay he's got a night this
is always an issue check check check
white dwarf it's on time euphorbia long
time I can just play moves them you
don't even have time ready to offer a
draw because if you do it loses too much
time at you lose you lose on time yeah I
came home this is the kind of result
that the game was like but I didn't
didn't kill it off probably I should
kill this off pretty convincingly I
didn't okay so this is a first first a
key situation here when you play deaf
for ya maybe of course he can play like
a 3d system Kings Indian Starwood which
is some leading to interesting play one
important point is that
black probably does not want to play
this as some he lacks the light squared
Bishop this piece on c8 that is often
instrumental in making this attack
dangerous you have to be able to play G
for sacrifice on h3 this kind of thing
is is an important thing that sentence I
probably keep the tension with castles
or c6 those kind of moves it leads to an
interesting play ok when f4 I took it
and this is probably not that grade
right yeah the engine agrees I mean
after this I'm probably just snatching
them and it's really not clear if this
is just something for white the thing is
I'm also active now and the bishop is
good yeah councils coming that's good
for black just just a pawn yeah um yeah
then we have seen else g5 and yeah the
engine is already giving wider a loss
basically which is probably what it is
objectively still you have to play it
it's not it's a pawn but it's also this
majority is completely having in whites
pieces so each form a g4 took a bit too
long for those moves and now have three
yeah I considered this awesome after
here f3 but I don't think this is bad
right now it's not bad but they are
three year what's interesting and all
the engine actually agrees with the
moment but it once the paper should be
five here ok whether it makes sense and
the bishop is strong 1e5 and black just
keeps every of everything intact that he
has and this that wasn't so good because
of Bishop f4 mmm that's not a move that
I considered my king is open now I mean
I'm here black seems to be fine but whoo
kingi 700 I pretty much doubt that I
would have played that move what about
looks like this is that bad oh he's got
queen age seven Chuck this is from me
okay right epitope case got the porn
back and I mean I was thinking my bishop
is the better pc over too well with this
King position you cannot count on that
and that that was CERN what you had to
do here so here jack yeah king in seven
was possible but the fastest is fine
yeah this is this g3 and why should
really not get out of this look at eight
but should be three how can I kill him
now king j that's what i did and now
Queen to h4 aha okay attacking c4 and
threatening night moves why that's very
strong this is if this means the Queen
right if I get it in so we cannot
actually cover that you know hear stuff
like define or this this is also
terrible yeah I should meet him but I
was kind of who I didn't see a made
another okay well okay let's trade
queens which is not the right recipe but
cat did this end game looks better like
but it is not not so easy to win qatar
and now I'm down to one extra corn and
it gets a quick fast now most Liam was
about clicking quickly cat yeah here we
we haven't for one thing I was so
ecstatic mr. there is a draw chair that
didn't really finish this game off as I
should have but um again I still think
it featured some interesting interesting
moments thanks for watching